[Music]
awesome hi everyone and welcome to the
talk if you're if you're feeling sad
that my voice is broken you have a
gentleman to thank that for so I do not
regret that but hi and welcome to the
talk a mojo I am planning to work I work
on nodejs and a lot of stuff as I told
you but talking about
internationalisation today I'm sorry I
just early I was not in the right kind
of food but so because I have to make
this about myself first I work on nodejs
also electron well and I contributed
different projects in the JavaScript
ecosystem now that includes v8 and test
- six - that's how I'm barely qualified
enough to talk about this subject
because I worked on some of the stuff
that relates to this right and also the
beauty and related things in the
ecosystem I'm a student as they pointed
out I been working with Google Summer of
Code for the past couple years and I'm a
speaker this this is not for you this is
for me to reassure myself all the time
times like you got this but so yeah I
about the talk actually so we need to
talk so we know how this works right a
couple of months ago I made a proposal
for something that I want to work on so
a lot of months ago I was working on
these things that was like oh it'd be so
amazing to talk to people about
and I I mean a CFP proposal for this and
I saw working on the talk and I realized
that I'll be talking at the awesome at
desk on fascia - oh you're some people
about this subject and a super stoked
one of my friends in Russia set up a
meetup group like - for me to test this
talk out I went to the meetup group
amazing young talented software
engineers sitting down listen to this
guy about internationalization and I
completely tanked the presentation like
it's it was so terrible that I like I
get chills till it's I'm getting
flashbacks so I thought maybe I could
like of course you're not as critical or
savage as the like Russians there was
like oh no but I thought I had the
courage to come up to this stage and
talk to you guys about that presentation
I I think I do not so let's skip it it's
it's super boring anyway
so yeah a lot of stuff I had when but oh
yeah atmosphere proposals right who
cares
so yeah you ever done I skip the like
entire presentation like three minutes
so yeah don't want to bother you
actually now that we have a bunch of
time and I'm a speaker and I oh yeah
I've got you ears let's talk about
something else
something that we all care about if
anybody is like even borderline sad that
that I you did not get to hear about
what you came here for let me tell you
about a cool website that I found on the
internet it's super amazing you
convinced so the deal how this works is
you can just go to the website and
you'll get my entire talk it's called
MDN so yeah that that was that was the
original top you you so if you scan this
QR code you go directly to the
internationalize
same page I'm sorry I cannot like come
up here and talk to you people about
like the nitty-gritties of the API
you'll just hate me for that so yeah go
there and this will drop you directly to
the intel page let's talk about
something else let's forget about the
talk it was boring and pretty much
useless let's talk about software
development right it's I hope everybody
is okay with that and let's talk about
software development because software is
hard right I mean so so let's get this
straight like you all spent like at
least three important days of your life
and and pretty much like most probably a
lot of money thousand dollars ticket
Jess conf right and like travel all that
stuff to listen to a bunch of nerds
talking about nerdy stuff like why would
he do that right you could spend that
time doing nice things you did that
because software is hard it's really
hard to do software and you want to like
do it better do it more efficiently you
know what else is hard currencies so so
I mean one of the things that I do is I
ask engineers to - when when you go back
to your company find the guy who works
with find the guy or the person working
on currencies and and payments and hug
them like really they're miserable
because currencies are hard and if you
think currencies are hard like me it the
the reason for that might not be that
you're as bad of a developer as I am
because currencies are hard for everyone
like the people who you look up to like
all the damn time screw up with
currencies all the damn time so there'd
be Google it's like so United States
always some arbitrary Omar years with my
three euros or it's it sucks when you
create your undefined civic type-r it's
like how do I pay you like not a number
dollars right
or when you get a leap late fee because
you do not know how to pay like to your
dollars Bethesda say a that that's an
awesome thing you should definitely pay
that much for that modify like you you
don't expect more if I do this like do I
paint pants do I pay in dollars do I
paint neither of those and and also like
obviously the almighty euro dollar
so it's hero is dollar it's your another
hero the next time
I think the hell right and and you know
you know this this is the right if you
if you work on product stuff if you work
on design this is these are the pretty
cool like microseconds right these are
the critical microseconds we have
already converted a user that they're
waiting to make that payment and the
users basically like shut up and take my
money like just this is the body we very
do not screw up right everything else
you got a free pass but like do not show
our payments because like you finally
convinced them to pave that's amazing
right some people kind of get it though
I mean like I like a lot of things about
some of the Google web sites for example
when I was giving this talk in Russia
like I already thanked the top talk and
they were deporting me they detected
that that I was in Russia and that I'd
probably use roubles to go and so they
deported me to the next slide mister
Latvia so I ended up being in Latvia and
I to go back home somehow so and then
they detected I had to use euros and
then coming here from home I on are you
go there you can go there right now it
probably detect you're in Singapore and
just like show you all the things in s
unique and that's great user experience
right so so how's this sound like like
get me through this it's easy so it no
hard rules really straightforward so in
in the english-speaking world it's
fairly easy right
so we use this is as God intended it to
me we have the decimal point when it
needs to be we have the comma separator
x' dollars pounds and euros of your
Island but but it thinks as soon as you
move out of the english-speaking world
things start to get complicated so you
can have like yeah yeah Europe I get
that like but why like I like that that
defies mathematics that's not like a
valid number that's why would you do
that it was like Europeans like oh it's
okay but like so many people live in
Europe and and like have some context
about this it's like it's fair to assume
like eighty percent of the people in the
world like probably have some idea about
this format so it's like it's still bad
if we look at this one and Latvians so
so that means used to use a space for
like the delimitation i'm like what it's
like that's not what do you use spaces
for but okay at least they're not using
stabs so and then it's like is that a
fraction like it's not what I do I do I
have to do math every time I'm like I
and of course the Japanese drop the drop
the fraction because there's no fraction
but like so so an Indonesian people like
you know Indonesian people in the
audience could like right we need to
talk so what the hell is this what the
hell is this because that that is
totally one point two three five I'm
gonna come up to you and I gotta pay you
one point two three five not and I think
it's not silly if you're reaching levels
of like confusing Ness but it's like I'm
not even joking anymore right so the
swiss franc using an apostrophe it's
it's not a valid number but it's about
its trained eyes and so this is
interesting if you're Canadian you
should like reconsider life choices
because so big
not [ __ ] you when I say if you're in
Canada if the person like the format in
which you write the currency depends on
which language the person is speaking in
so you write that if they're speaking
English you write this if they're
speaking in French it's like how how do
you determine that's like do you wear a
tag it's like it says French and then
people like Izumo they're they're
probably not as smart but but yeah it
doesn't have to be that way so let's
talk about the the most important thing
life let's talk about anxiety is what I
feel when I work in multiple currencies
and it doesn't have to be that way let's
fix this so we did if you go to your
browser if you go to your friend
friendly browser right now or know Jess
and and try this API so you go currency
you go Canadian dollars boom
English you got that French you got that
and it's like it that's just one
currency in two languages you can you
can try that with all combinations it
just works
it takes out like so you can have
variables for the currency and for the
language and then like it you can take
the guesswork out of the printing you
can just you do not use a static string
just like number format your currencies
and so so I'm sorry right for what I'm
gonna say next but I have bad news it's
like I hate to be the bearer of bad news
but it's not just currencies that are
hard right internationalization is hard
it's really damn hard so so actually oh
this is we we have a small problem so so
I was Brian to talk about a lot of other
things actually with just one next thing
but the problem about this is I cannot I
think because like a lot of you are not
as smart as me and do not know as much
math so I think we need to like revisit
some of the fundamentals if I like want
to want you to be at the same level of
thinking as me I am of course so
let's let's take a couple of minutes to
revisit the fundamentals if that's okay
yeah first class of kindergarten
counting so so let's let's start
counting and we all love cats right so
so let's count cats so you're one cat
you've six cats and you have zero point
seven cats now don't ask me how that
works maybe maybe you have like nine
roommates and seven cats between all of
you but like yeah so but like if you see
the pattern here English is like two
when it comes to claw realization
English as like two things which is one
not one which is like pretty simple it's
like it's either one or not one like it
might be a fraction it might be like non
one number but it's not one and
polarization is easy life is good
let's actually let's so let's move on to
a different breed of cats Welsh cats and
Counting Welsh cats you have zero Kitab
you one get the 1.5 cat you have to get
your three got your six yet you're 42
cat so pluralization is in English
and that's just death that's just the
second language that's just velch and
feels like so do SuperDuper close to
England right that's like how do you
[ __ ] that up
but like you you go to like countries
across the world
Arabic is like for plural forms and like
languages of like plural forms so
English has like one and other and and
other languages that few and many and
like how do you determine that looks
like it's so hard to figure this stuff
out but it doesn't have to be so we have
a plural rules API for stuff like this
so you can you can tell it okay English
us I like beef jerky but PR just like
zero it'll throw up other 0.5 other one
is one and everything else is other you
can just use this underlying low level
API to determine what plural drew you
need to use and you could I'm going to
show a bunch of code next please do not
bother with like trying to read all of
that it's like just just trying to
demonstrate make a point you'll get the
code later on but you can use this
underlying API if you notice to to spin
up a quick script to like format your
sentence right so English and just
change it slightly and make it work for
Welch and this is this an amazing API
you can use it for ordinals
so you've got 0 at first second third
fourth 11th and 21st forty second
hundred third in any language that you
want so these examples that I showed you
I I'm not smart enough to write them but
the amazing people at v8 are and they
have like a huge blog post op it
explains the all the feature in detail
it's amazing you can also find the code
there just scan the QR code if you want
to just follow this link but yeah that's
that's that API so like let's let's talk
about now that you're talking about
stuff I have
zoo Asian right everybody loves relative
time expressions like you do not want to
know that your driver is for 42 seconds
away though but like the other
observation I have is nobody really
knows how to do it
and and everybody tries to do it I'm
like I'm just playing a video game it's
like what what is that number
do it do I reach one this year I just
want to play csgo and why is that so
specific it's like what's gonna happens
that is that like the next Eclipse or
something but but you don't have to like
you don't have to be like super smart to
do it anymore because you also have an
API for that so relative time formatting
it's called relative time format numeric
auto is like the format but you want it
to be in you can like do it short narrow
whatever and and - one day is yesterday
zero day is today one day is tomorrow -
one week is last week zero week is this
week one week is next week that's so
cool right now they you can do this you
could already do this like this is this
is not that hard to do you'd be thinking
but I'll leave up to your imagination
how hard it is to do in multiple
languages if you want to support like 15
languages you're not gonna do it on your
own and you'll not been people have been
trying to do this kind of stuff relative
time formatting especially on the
internet for like all the time and
you'll probably do it as well you might
use something like moment or globalize
but definites with that now there's a
problem with this and and where my segue
into that is gonna be this right so I'm
sorry but Laurie who you might find
Brown is like better react in the
browser you comments and I it's like
it's a joke we get it but then if you
think about it Laurie's on to something
right I mean like how many of you are
friend developers by the way people who
do front-end stuff that's
quite a few I cannot say anybody but
that's quite a few people yes and the
so bill reactant or browser you comments
and so you are making front-end web
sites and the thing is that you like
pretty much every modern front-end web
site like uses some sort of decent dome
API right you use react or something and
it's like why can't you just standardize
that that will shave off your bundle
sizes that would also like make a
standard API then people can that people
can just build upon and then and people
are doing that people are expanding the
web platform virtual Dom we're coming to
the HTML standard so that's cool like
talking about these kind of things let's
talk about sizes and like this is
completely safe for work but so so react
and react I by the way I do not want to
be controversial about this please do
not separate me I have no idea what
these words even mean like I I just
write C++ please leave me alone Twitter
but this is just data but like because
people come up to me is like oh yeah
isn't that supposed to be half the size
of Rick I do not know you tell me but
but react is is six like it's 187
kilobytes if you if you react in itself
is a package that has a huge download
it's like around 60 kaveri but then
people come up to me it's like it's not
what it has to the bundle it's just what
you download it's like fair enough so it
just had six one five kilobytes to the
bundle while pre-act adds 900 bytes now
that's basically cheating because if you
also add react on that basically adds
like 104 kilobytes which is like but but
let's not dwell into that again but so
comparing the magnitude you add in view
and it's like it's sixty three point
five kilobytes if you just see the the
bundle size and then when you are
an angle that does this angle the slash
core so so you need a bunch of other
angular modules as well to make angular
websites but let's compare that to the
seal D our data now we gotta talk about
this because so that's over six
megabytes for dates you need numbers to
work with dates so that's four point
three megabytes another one and but
there's a huge likes earlier or also
data that you need and then this like
obviously you need something to query
this data with so you need a Jas library
for that and other like but these are so
abysmally small compared to these that
like let's not even talk about that
right but that data is large imagine
having this so I tried to like include
the the bundle size which is the same
because like this is JSON
you can't tree shake that right you need
all the data you need like you can't
just drop languages but so so if you
like have to compile all that data and
push that video bundle that's like over
it 11 megabytes if you have a manager
even somewhat like the managers I've
seen it's a non-starter like 11
megabytes in no way but it's the
relative time format API you know how
much the model size and this one is zero
because it's built in the browser and
and you can you go from narrow 3/4 one
day and you can go for Spanish which is
so cool a lot vien or yeah this does not
make any sense or Chinese and this is so
cool right you can just use these two to
check out what yesterday and today is I
tomorrow is I pretty much wrote a script
just to know what these words are in
different languages I have nothing to do
and so it's like what about comparing
strings by the way yay we have got later
for that because for some reason the
Germans deal with the Avett accents
completely different from the Swedish
it's like did they're right across the
border like get this sorted out right
it's like just but yeah you if you want
to compare strings if you want to sort
strings or search strings which you have
to do like so so many damn time you can
use this for that
it's local specific and people people
come up to me when I talk about this API
and they would be like oh imagine the
possibilities we have so this date time
formatting less formatting like again
these all things were despite whichever
language you're working on this
segmenting so you can iterate over
sentences paragraphs whatever you don't
have to like do dot split period because
like that only works so so far right and
and it's all a part of to please come
help out now I think I can mirror my
display on this one okay if you go can I
use for internationalization it's
putting all over the boat like most of
the internationalization features you
can use in your applications right now
if you say the test to six to rip out on
the internationalization API test this
was the day we people put up this
website remove cha-cha Creek or our IP
and if you if you see the
internationalisation API it started off
with around 57% coverage with v8 going
71 yeah in spider monkey 50% JavaScript
poor for the 8% okay and if you see that
the day the numbers have improved right
so as of yesterday actually we didn't
build it today yet and remove a little
excess also if we don't care about it
it's 61 percent and
he's hitting 86% and spider monkeys
improve to 54 javascriptcore says at 44
but like things are improving things are
getting better the deaths like the
number of tests increase between that
time so it's like even if somebody
stayed at the same number they added
some features
I'd say v8 is like technically if you
look at it we it is pretty much 100%
covered a lot of this comes from like
features landing in v8 right now plus
like one API which is called v8 brake
iterator which we have like they handle
differently it's like yeah if you're
using no GS if you're using if it
refuses use Chrome which I think they do
I mean the numbers a 10 you can or any
chromium based browser for that matter
you can be perfectly sure that this will
like chess work right so please use
internationalization API Singapore is
the only big GS Khan city that I can go
to and be like four languages you know
how bad it is right and people like yes
because like Jess Condon for us people
would be like oh yeah just use English
I'm like that's not the point
okay so yeah thank you for that stuff
and there's actually also on the tank a
bunch of awesome people before I leave
so there's Satya works on we thank you
for all your work on
internationalization and thank you also
for like helping me out working on
internationalization so much you're
amazing thanks to my peers for helping
with this talk so much you're the best
thanks for Rick at tc39 for for helping
me through all my work with this desk
and and all this stuff
Thank You Steven for like literally be
the only person at no js' who keeps
upgrading I see you I hope I can help
you more in the next few days
thank you to the awesome people worked
when we ate me excluded obviously and
thank you to the tc39 committee and
thank you to the organizers you
amazing people thank you and and I'd
like to thank you all
also for oh I'd like to thank you all
for attending this talk and yeah see you
are on and if you have any questions
feel free to hit me up that's what I'm
here for
yay
[Applause]